there was a dude once who was like I
want to come on stage with you and I was
like I don't I don't understand that
request and he goes if you let me come
on stage I'll let somebody in the
audience come on stage and kick me in
the nuts I'm like come on up
and so I asked the crowd I'm like who
wants to come kick this dude in the nuts
in this one woman clearly had probably
just got out of a terrible relationship
and she was like I don't kick it in the
nuts right now and I was like
and the guy said to me he got nervous he
was like anybody else
I'm like no this is who's coming up
so I made him sit like this she goes I
don't want to kick him I go listen
it's Philadelphia
one of you is going to get booed
it's either you for not kicking him or
him for not going down and she was like
I'm gonna kick him I go get in there she
started doing this behind them to
stretch
and I turned the guy I go you are in
trouble
she's doing this she's like let me
stretch it out I'm like yeah do what you
need to do girl she gave herself a
little and then just
lifted him like this
and made the movie noise
like that I was like oh that really
happens
dropped him was amazing I've I've tried
to replicate it nobody else will let me